what separated you from peers who didn't
get as far as you did
um I think that like a love for what
you're doing is very important I think
if you love if you truly love what
you're doing I see kids pushing to
sports because their parents wanted want
them to do it or push into things
because go and do that job because it's
going to make you money but they don't
have a love for it it's it's just
different it's much more clunky and hard
so I think love is the first thing I
think just being routine based I'm very
routine I most CD on things I like my
organization set out like this like I
have cleaners come clean the house and
I'll move I'm not losing my mind
like where hang on a second I know this
was you know someone of those guys not
OCD where it has to be perfect but I've
got an order about things in my brain
you know so I think being organized and
having a routine is really important and
I I had that as a young fella you know
before school I train go to school after
school or train come back at home shoot
in the backyard I just have a routine
that I was just getting
um used to so once you become
professional it's kind of easy so
they're probably the two biggest thing
you need a lot of routine you gotta put
the words yeah everyone says oh it's all
about hard work but it really is you
know the ten thousand hours I think to
master a craft is that it pretty short
number
um it's ten thousand hours to to master
a craft of whatever you're doing so you
know if you're a young kid and you're 14
and do the math how much are you
spending a day times out by the how many
days in the year and you know you want
to become a professional well you got to
be hitting that 10 000 Mark closer to
your 20s right so that's that's what
it's all about and I think put time you
know and also the other thing you know
our society I think that that is is to
do is failure I think failures I a huge
huge key ingredient to success you know
most people I don't know exactly your
previous business Journeys or how do you
cancer to what you're doing today but
like you have to fail fail is the most
honest brutal way to figure out what
you've done wrong you know your friends
and family aren't going to tell you like
I said if you do something wrong then
I'm gonna they're gonna tell you
politically correct way or they're
scared to hurt your feelings when you
fail when business goes under you don't
make it to you and you get cut from the
team you fail a diploma
that's it it's brutal like there's no
bill on end all the smart people won't
part about that for three years and feel
sorry for themselves and become a victim
have a week where you might have a
future many drinks and you you're mad at
the world and get out of whiteboard and
be like okay this is what I did and what
do I need to do better to fix that and
all the good A lot of the successful
people in life are failure I think we
should really Embrace fail now there's a
difference if you're failing doing it
again failing do it again there's an
issue there like you're doing the same
thing over and over and getting the same
result is obviously a big underlying
issue but I think
on the general consensus like that
failures taboo I think we need to
embrace that a little bit more just
because it's a really really brutal
learning curve
and I think that's so important and it's
such an important lesson for kids and
why sport is so important for kids
because it's a safe place for them to
fail you know you play your team you do
your best you lose all right well what
do I learn from this how can I improve
next time
yeah and I'm going through it with my
son he's playing soccer at the moment
and
um I'm not worried about goal scored all
I care about is effort and you know kids
look at goal scorers they've played well
that's what they're gonna release well I
scored goals right so it's playing
soccer and he's a bigger jib so it took
him a while to catch up to the the speed
and the footwork of the smaller more
stockier kids which is great but I put
in that for that very reason and you
know there's a few games where he wasn't
at the ball passed through you know kids
are a little selfish at that age which
is normal uh well they lose and like you
know he's tearing up and one game he
basically you know somewhat quit you
know he struggled for the last 15
minutes of the game and didn't want to
be out there and I didn't let him play
the next weekend just let him train uh
then let him play in a big carnival that
he was looking forward to unfortunately
was the hardest thing I did as a parent
I said you're not playing in the
carnival you fix this
um and then we came back to trading and
doing the one-on-one drill and he and he
kicked the goal and hit hit the in the
trainings hit the the left the left the
post and the right post the VAR would
let it be a goal but uh was like no goal
and he I could seem you know get
interior eyed and about to shut down and
I just yell you're right anti-beared up
he came out of the drill and then by the
time he got the front of the line again
he he conned himself and that was the
proudest thing I've ever done I've ever
done I didn't care about the goal I
didn't care about everything else he
self-released himself as a six-year-old
got back in the drill and actually
scored a goal so like I was like Matt
like that's
that is I was so happy with that more
than anything else because I think it's
very important and he's used that
failure you know the carnival and all
that kind of stuff and and figured out
okay I've had a bad minute I'm not going
to let this turn into a bad five minutes
into a bad day into into two weeks three
weeks four weeks so I'm a constant
battle without my kids and I think it's
a very important lesson they have to
learn no they have to learn failure they
have to learn missing they have to learn
being subbed out they have to learn a
coach not liking them they have to learn
how teacher doesn't like him sometimes
that's life you're gonna you have to
deal with that so if you can get that to
him in an early age
um Dana White I don't know if you saw
his interviews from a little while ago
he said the kids that are brought up in
that sense to be a little bit tougher
and gritty to get absolutely own the
Next Generation and once they're once
they're adults because there's
alternative those kids
thank you